Since the nuclear deal was signed a year
ago, Iran, for the most part, has kept up
the very technical terms of the deal.
It has reconfigured its centrifuges; it has
filled the heavy-water reactor in Iraq
that could produced plutonium; and they've
shipped out most of their
enriched uranium stockpile.
So they have followed the letter of the
law when it comes to the nuclear deal
for the most part. At the same time,
they're trying to push the envelope on
what we would consider the spirit of the
deal, which is launching ballistic
missiles that could potentially deliver
nuclear weapons in the future, which Iran
says, "Hey, that's not really technically
part of the deal, so we don't have any
compunction about actually launching
missiles,"
no matter how much it may upset the US.
So I think what you're going to see in
the coming months and years as we head
into the next administration, is Iran
continuing to push the envelope on its
research and development, ballistic
missile testing, as well as other parts
of the nuclear program that should cause us
a lot of concern.
So I think this is going to be a huge
problem for the next president.